what's up guys we're here at gardens by
the bay flower dome we are testing out
the all-new vivo x80 pro in the house
it's been out for a few months here we
recently got it in singapore we're
actually recording in cinematic mode
with classic movie lut as we're doing
this portion of the video we're going to
test out the photos the videos we're
gonna see what the hype is with all this
zeiss integration into it so let's get
down to it let's have fun with the x80
pro
before we kick things off big thanks to
vivo singapore for sending over the
phone our way having said that these are
my thoughts and my thoughts only and the
audio if you're in case you're wondering
is coming from the dji mic into the
phone with usbc adapter so with that
let's talk about this phone let's have
some fun zeno
let's do it
yeah
all right guys so
talking about the phone of course it's
the snapdragon 8th gen 1. you've got a
4700 milliamp battery inside of this you
got four cameras got a 50 megapixel a 48
ultra wide you've got an 8 and a 12 in
terms of the telephoto ranges so you're
pretty stacked when it comes to cameras
and of course the zeiss integration is a
big proponent of this and that's why
we're here to talk about this
the phones most android phones are the
snapdragon 8th gen 1 processor work
great the vivo is no exception it's
fantastic it's fast it's fluid no
hiccups no stuttering this is a beast of
a phone but is it a content creator's
tool is it something that we want to buy
because of that zeiss name we know that
uh recently xiaomi has partnered up with
leica since the huawei partnership has
ended and people are hyped about that
but i'm telling you this zeiss what i'm
seeing inside of this phone
may put you guys on the fence on which
one to go with and you may opt for the
vivo x80 pro i'm just putting that out
there reason being there's some really
awesome specs inside of this and some
features that i think people are going
to really enjoy especially if you're
into photography vintage lenses from
zeiss biotar sonars planars all that
great stuff you're going to really enjoy
this and as you're seeing in the
cinematic video mode right this this
looks damn good right got the nice
background bokeh it looks pretty damn
natural of course this is ai kicking in
on this but it looks good xeno do i look
good in this
right you got a nice kind of wide screen
aspect
right and it looks real it looks natural
which is what you want uh we actually
recorded the earlier portion just in 4k
without anything on it because when
you're doing cinematic mode you can only
do it in 1080 unfortunately but you know
what for social media for instagram for
facebook that's all you need anyway 4k
you can't use
you can't use it
trust us we know we have to shrink our
file sizes down all the time
but
anyway so let's go into the photo mode
we're gonna talk about that right now
we're gonna talk about what it's like to
shoot photos or do these bokeh effects
from the sonar planar biotar all of that
stuff does it make a big difference or
is it just all high let's find out all
right so now let's talk about some of
the photography features of the x80 pro
now of course the zeiss integration
which is important so you have a variety
of different lens uh characteristics
biotar planar sonar um
the list goes on and on inside of this
thing plus you have nostalgia you have
different film
uh
simulations in this you've got various
different filters and you've got
lighting effects you've got light leaks
you've got so many things that you can
add
into your images it's kind of like vsco
lightroom
and of course
vivo's magic with zeiss all in one so it
gives you a lot of creativity with your
images and it does make them quite
unique and of course with the ai it'll
boost up colors it will kind of play
with exposure a little bit now it's not
a hundred percent accurate like these um
bokeh effects from zeiss like these v of
the various different lenses some of
them are hip miss to be honest with you
some of them can look a little synthetic
and some can look natural of course you
can drop down the bokeh or bring it up
to adjust to make it look as natural as
you want it to be but it's something to
take into consideration of now we are
going to be showing you images that i've
taken in xeno he's taking of me with
these various different effects to give
you an idea what you can do with that
also other images that i've taken out on
the streets
with this camera system but overall it's
fun and of course in pro mode you can
shoot in raw and you can shoot in jpeg
but raw coming out of a smartphone i
would say isn't really the best you know
what i mean because these are small
camera systems i think
i would say
iphone probably does it the best when it
comes out of raw because it's not a
full raw image it's sort of a
raw baked in with some goodies to kind
of keep it looking clean and keep it
looking as good as possible but overall
i like the images i think they're fun i
think for social media they're great i
mean would i use these for professional
work hard to say i i'm a camera guy i
like my big cameras i like medium format
i like film cameras i like professional
cameras but i think for fun i think
these are fantastic and i think for a
lot of you out there that are just
looking for a really cool smartphone
camera system this is when to look at it
so with that we're going to show you
some more photo and video samples then
we'll come back with our final thoughts
[Music]
so final thoughts on the x80 pro i
really like this phone it's a fun phone
to use the video looks really good yes
the cinematic mode isn't perfect you're
going to get some sort of lines around
the bokeh at times but it's really cool
like i said you can adjust this and you
can play around with the luts but i love
the integration with zeiss i mean you're
getting all these various different
bokeh effects some work some don't work
as well as others you get the cinema
modes you get the movie luts there's a
lot of cool features that will keep you
entertained for quite some time and give
you some really cool things to play with
especially if you want to put up content
on tiktok instagram facebook whatever
social media platform you want to use i
mean how does it compare to let's say
the xiaomi 12 volt shirt with leica we
don't have that phone yet but i have
used the uh huawei version with the
leica collaboration i had to say that
there's more integration with zeiss then
i saw with leica in that so i think it's
very interesting and it's interesting to
see what's going to happen in the future
but if you're looking for a really cool
android phone with something different
with some really good optics some good
cameras some pretty kick-ass video
this may be one to consider anyway those
are my thoughts on the vivo x80 pro let
me know your thoughts in the comment
section below if you like this video hit
that like button subscribe to the
channel also hit that notification bell
we got a lot of great content on geek
culture coming your way with that guys
take care stay safe and chat to you soon
[Music]
you